what holds a person's character is a
chain of offense but sharp that person's
life I personally chose to study law my
father also studied law man if I believe
in justice which is why I chose this
field a Hanning deputy and I decided to
defend human rights Shirin Ebadi was
awarded for 2003 Nobel Peace Prize for
her efforts for democracy and human
rights she has focused especially on the
struggle for the rights of women and
children seven years after receiving her
Nobel Peace Prize the body hasn't
stopped her pioneering efforts for
democracy and social justice one she
care Angus Imani what's motivates me
when I wake up every morning buffet then
there's the thought of political
activists imprison a tyranny of them
here
my colleagues were imprisoned young
students who represent Georgia only care
how they are being tortured and
persecuted in Iran into horizontals and
under and that is what drives me shake
and emission in the mandira bedi yeah
that is what compels me to carry on with
this fight Ricky
Adama be damned
her committed pursuit of peace has made
Shirin Ebadi an international symbol not
only for democracy but for women's
rights around the world and particularly
the rights of Muslim women women
constitute half of any society's
population so it's natural that they
play a very effective part it's women
Massa raise children and future
generations who will have an impact on
their society so it's important and
vital that women are given an active
role and so I repeat women must not by
any government the continuous struggle
for human rights concerns not only those
living under a repressive system but
each and every one of us hey buddy
urges us to widen our perspective as
global citizens that bring change to the
world we have to bring chance to others
half guess where the change begins from
within each and every one of us I have
to change the way we think one hours
instead of focusing on ourselves as
individuals the honover them all or on
our family's mission or even our own
nation well you see we have to think
generally
Ana's Anika dad to think of human rights
for women in Africa happiness it walls
any care or muslin salmon Middle East
well yes he should have a united sense
of sympathy empathy in not the starting
point for Shirin Ebadi
awakening a sense of compassion and
fighting for change our missions that
never end
d-danny when I see the Sun Rise only it
reminds me on the Monday night has
passed and life is Camilla Hadassah
mentioned a new life students every day
as long as the life we live